une reprise de procès très attendu
c'était la première apparition publique
de julian assange depuis février dernier
après avoir confirmé son identité sa
date de naissance
le lanceur d'alerté australien a déclaré
formellement ne pas consentir à son
extradition
poursuivi notamment pour espionnage par
la justice américaine
ils risquent 175 ans de prison aux états
unis
une expulsion inenvisageable pour ses
défenseurs il s'agit d'un cas global
dans lequel les états unis souhaite
arracher quiconque ne leur plaît pas en
utilisant des enlèvements
extraterritoriaux qui compte ne les aime
pas sera ramené dans leurs cachots aux
états unis en particulier s'il est
poursuivi par le ministère de la justice
la force de cette communauté et la force
du système judiciaire du royaume uni et
la vigueur de la frontière autour de la
vie nationale ici dépendront de la
direction que prendra cette affaire
si julian ne se fait pas extradé alors
je suppose que la force du royaume uni
et de son système judiciaire seront un
exemple pour le monde à l'extérieur de
la cour de justice
plusieurs dizaines de soutien de julian
assange ont manifesté une quarantaine
d'organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme et de la liberté de la presse
août appelé à sa libération immédiate
nous appelons vraiment les etats-unis à
abandonner immédiatement les accusations
elle n'aurait jamais dû être portée
contre lui en premier lieu parce que les
accusations le tiennent responsable de
la publication d'informations ce que les
éditeurs et les journalistes s'efforcent
de faire chaque jour pour protéger
l'intérêt public
nous parlons ici d'éventuels crimes de
guerre et d'autres violations graves des
droits de l'homme commises par l'armée
américaine
les autorités britanniques ne doivent
pas l'envoyer de quelques manières que
ce soit aux états unis
à l'issue de ces trois à quatre semaines
de débats la cour décidera si julian
assange doit être extradé ou non vers
les états unis
une décision qui ne marquera pas pour
autant la fin de son combat judiciaire
quoi qu'il arrive la décision devrait
faire l'objet d'un appel